Hallo, mein Name ist Demrel und ich bin der Disabendass und für Sie zuständig.
Ich werde eine Frage zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt zu Ihrer Beschwerde übergehen.
Wie heißt sie?
Frau Vogel Andrea.
Vogel Andrea?
Andrea.
Was ist Ihr Nachname?
Vogel.
Mit V?
Mit V, wie Vogel, genau.
Wie heißt sie, Herr Vogel?
Na ja, dann machen wir Herr Vogel, das ist gut.
Ich bin 50 Jahre alt.
Wie wann Sie sich gerne geboren?
Erster 1970.
Herr Vogel, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für Sie tun?
Ich habe seit einer Zeit so ein voller Gefühl, so schnell, sofort 30 oder 40 Minuten nach der Mahlzeit.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er kommt, aber das ist echt unangenehm.
Wenn ich so eine kleine Position, die ich zu mich einnehme, dann habe ich sofort ein voller Gefühl.
Mehr geht das nicht weiter.
Natürlich habe ich zu dem so eine Bauchschmerzen ab und zu, so eine kampfartige Bauchschmerz.
Ja, das stört mich schon.
Das ist nicht eine Geschichte, das ist seit gestern, sondern auch seit mehr als 2-3 Monaten.
Seit 2-3 Monaten.
Vielleicht noch länger, aber seit 2-3 Monaten ist es eher vermehrt.
Nach 7 Monaten ist es noch ein bestimmtes Ernährungs-Ton.
Nach der Mahlzeit, oder nicht, dass ich einfach gewöhnt war,
dass ich nach einer richtigen Mahlzeit so eine volle Gefühl habe,
nach einer kleinen Position, nach einer 3-4 Löffel, habe ich dann sofort so ein voller Gefühl.
Ich habe keine mehr Lust, weil ich fast voll bin, zu essen, so zu sagen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Kraft als Gebauchsmessen haben.
Können Sie sich für mich das nicht messen, genau wie ich es habe?
Ja, das ist ein U-Bauchbereich.
Das ist auch ab und zu, das ist nicht dauerhaft.
Ich muss auch zugeben, dass ich auch schon Gericht abgenommen habe.
Wie viel Kilogramm haben Sie abgenommen?
Ungefähr 3-4 Kilo.
In den nächsten 3 Monaten, oder länger?
Noch mal bitte.
Ungefähr so 3-4 Monate, würde ich sagen.
Wie viel Tag sind Sie messen beim Attacken?
Auf einer Schmerz-Karabine 1 bis 10.
Einsteht vielleicht um 10, 5 Steht.
Wenn ich Schmerzen habe,
muss ich sagen, dass ich nicht so habe.
Das Sehen ist, dass ich nicht Schmerzen habe.
Das ist das Sehen.
Da muss ich etwas einnehmen, damit die Beschwerden sich etwas erleichtern können.
Das dauert auch etwas.
Unterschiedlich, manchmal nehme ich Nauvalgene,
manchmal nehme ich Epipropfene ein.
Aber ich habe ein Gefühl, dass Nauvalgene besser ist als Epipropfene.
Wie viel Kilogramm?
Da gibt es Tabletten, 500 oder 1000,
wie gestärkt ist das, aber ich glaube, 500.
Manchmal nehme ich 2 Stück einmal, wenn das nicht geht.
Darf ich es in einer anderen Perikon aus?
Ob ich eine Ausstrahlung habe.
An den Rücken habe ich auch Schmelzen.
Zwischen 2 Schulterbein habe ich auch Schmelzen.
An der rechten Seite habe ich auch Schmelzen.
Wo habe ich nicht gehört?
An der Flanke.
Unter Rippen, ja.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Haben Sie Erbrocken oder Essinenübel?
Übelkeit habe ich, habe ich nicht.
Aber wenn ich Schmeistertage habe, habe ich es mir schlecht.
Wie lange haben Sie Übelkeit?
Seit ungefähr, ja, das als ich gesagt habe,
während der Schmeistertage habe ich es nicht.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie ungefähr 3-4 Kilogramm abgenommen haben
in den nächsten 4 Monaten.
Wie viel wegen Sie derzeit?
Das aktuell, ungefähr so 70 Kilogramm.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,80.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder beim Wasserlassen?
Beim Wasserlassen nicht, aber beim Wasserlassen habe ich keine Probleme.
Aber ich habe eine Verstoffung.
Seit wann habe ich Verstoffung?
Ja, ab und zu, nicht jeden Tag.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich mehr Luft habe.
Ich gehe auch nicht regelmäßig, 3-4 Tage einmal.
Manchmal habe ich auch eine Fettstunde.
Ich spüre das auch, wenn ich spüre, ist es auch so fertig.
Es ist ein bisschen unangenehm, es riecht auch schlecht.
Haben Sie Schlockprobleme?
Ja, seit 2 Monaten schon.
Haben Sie Durchschlafen?
Durchschlafen.
Haben Sie weitere Beschwerde?
Weitere Beschwerde habe ich nicht.
Das kommt alles zusammen.
Ich kann nicht differenzieren, weil ich noch hatte.
Ich kann Ihre Fragen beantworten.
Haben Sie Beläume?
Ich habe vorhin erwähnt, dass ich so viel Luft habe.
Das klingt schon nach Beläumen.
Haben Sie Fieber gehabt bisher?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen, die Sie vorgeschrieben haben.
Haben Sie Corona-Krankheiten?
Nein, eigentlich auch nicht.
Ich habe so einen Blutdruck.
Ich nehme so eine Medikamente.
Ich bin auch nicht kriegermäßig.
Aber für mich mit einer Medikamente ist das gut angestellt.
Seit wann haben Sie Blutdruck?
Seit ungefähr 5 Jahren.
Also nehme ich es ein.
Wie ist es mit der Anfang?
Am Lodipin?
Ja, das ist das.
Wie viel Milligramm?
2,5 Milligramm.
Einmal morgen.
Ich habe noch andere Corona-Krankheiten.
Noch mal bitte.
Nein, nein.
Ich nehme es aus der Medikamente.
Ich nehme es auch aus der Medikamente.
Ich nehme etwas aus dem Schmerz.
Ich nehme nichts aus dem Schmerz.
Ok.
Hast du dich schon in der Operatour gemacht?
Ja, ich habe eine Blinde am OP.
10 Jahre.
Hast du einen Unfall gehabt?
Nein, ich habe keinen Unfall.
Hast du gegen die Medikamente-Allergie oder Reagieren auf etwas allergisch?
Nein, ich bin nicht bekannt.
Hast du durchgeimpft?
Noch mal bitte.
Hast du durchgeimpft gegen die Kleider?
Nein, ich bin voll geimpft.
Und du?
Ja, genau.
Auch gebustet.
Jetzt komme ich zu Ihrer Lebensbegehörnheit.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, leider.
Seit 10 Jahren?
Seit 10 Jahren.
Und wie viel?
20 pro Tag.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, und so.
Was ist auch, können Sie für mich den Abendbecher?
Ja, jeden Tag zwei, drei Bier und dann Wochenende mal Schnaps.
Nicht so viel.
Nehmen Sie diese Frage bitte nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routine-Probe, die ich Ihnen stellen muss.
Und haben Sie bisher mit dem Dragon Contact gehabt?
Nein, habe ich nie.
Und haben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ja, ein, würde ich sagen.
Ich bin ein bisschen vor Ort.
Was ist ja ein?
Ja, manchmal schon, manchmal nicht.
So ein regelmäßig mache ich nicht, aber ich habe immer Lust zu machen.
Aber es klappt nicht leider.
Herr Vogel, sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, habe ich keine.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Taxifahrer.
Herr Vogel, wo wohnen Sie in einer Wohnung?
Ich wohn mit meinen Freunden zusammen.
Herr Vogel, ich habe noch eine Frage nach Ihrer Familie.
Wie ist die Kinder-Familie?
Meine Bruder hat einen Warenkrebs vor 10 Jahren verstritten.
Der war damals 60 Jahre alt.
Und ansonsten meine Eltern.
Leben Sie da?
Ja, die leben noch.
Meine Mutter ist schon 80 Jahre alt.
Die leidet unter Blutzuckerkrankheit, aber die nimmt nur Tabletten.
Einfach keinen Solen.
Und mein Vater hat so eine Blutdruckdruckdruck.
Der nimmt auch nur einfach zwei Tabletten,
auch sie sind morgen und abends.
Ansonsten sind die kein gesund.
Ich habe noch ein paar Tage mitgebracht.
Ich habe schon zwei Monate mitgebracht.
Ich habe auch noch ein paar Tage mitgebracht.
Ich habe noch ein paar Tage mitgebracht.
Sie haben gesagt, dass sie in den letzten 3 bis 4 Minuten drei Bispekuloren abgenommen.
Sie haben sich im Atak bei 10 eingeholt und gegen diese Schmerzen haben sie einen neuen Profi eingegangen.
Sie haben sich in den Rücken und in den Schulterbeinen geblieben.
Sie haben auch die Lärmung im Bauch, besonders nach dem Essen.
Beim Essen haben sie auch Übelkeit und ab uns haben sie Verstoffung.
Alle 3 bis 4 Tage gehen einmal auf die Toilette.
Die Konsistenz der Schutul ist fertig.
Sie haben gesagt, dass sie kein Fieber haben.
Sie haben leider an Bluthochdruck und gegen Amelieb hin eingegangen.
Sie haben bei Ihnen durchgeführt.
Haben Sie Erfolgen aber Fragen an mich?
Ich habe keine Fragen. Ich will gerne etwas schauen, wie lange ich noch hier bleibe.
Herr Vogel, Sie haben seit langem Schmerzen.
Ich werde Sie über die Körperleuchter untersuchen.
Ihr Bauchabtastung abhören.
Ich werde Sie gleich ein Ultraschall dünn und Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Dann können wir Sie in der Genoure vergeschenken.
Danke schön.
Haben Sie etwas vergessen?
Ich glaube schon, dass wir etwas vergessen haben.
Sie haben es doch gemacht.
Aber ich frage Sie, ob Sie noch etwas vertiefen können.
Wenn Sie nicht ein Asthast-Gespräch geben, dann finden Sie etwas vergessen.
Aber Sie haben auch Schmerzen gehört.
Ja, gute Frage.
Die habe ich auch gehabt.
Das war nicht in dieser Maß.
Vor zwei Monaten habe ich auch gehabt, aber nicht so stark.
Mit Schmerzmittel konnte ich so recht kommen.
Die Schmerzmittel war ausreichend.
Ich musste nicht ins Krankenhaus gehen.
Ich habe noch Fragen im Chat.
Ich kann fragen.
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Aber weil man meistens nicht merkt,
dass man nicht stark Äkterus hat.
Man spürt manchmal Äkterus nicht.
Man schaut sich hinterher im Spiegel.
Das ist normal.
Außer wenn jemand von außen das feststellt.
Das ist ein sehr dünner Ruhin.
Das haben wir alles gut analysiert.
Außer noch eine Frage.
Alkohol?
Seit wie lang getrieben ist so viel Alkohol?
Seit wann?
Das haben Sie auch nicht gefragt.
Das haben Sie auch nicht vergessen.
Sie haben es gut gemacht.
Das ist nur ein kleines Kritik.
Das ist normal.
Dann machen wir weiter.
Ich habe einen neuen Patenten aufgenommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen.
Ich habe es kurz vorgenommen.
Das haben Sie für mich gesprochen?
Ja!
Andrez Fogul, 50 Jahre alt.
Ungebührt am ersten ersten 1970.
1,80 m groß und 70 kg.
Es ist Taxifahrer nicht verheiratet.
und lebt mit ihrem Front zusammen.
Ja, herfogel bestellt sich heute bei uns wegen seit ungefähr zwei Monaten,
Bechtende und Kraftartike, besonders nach dem Essen aufgetretene Schmerzen vor.
Volle Gefühle war das, ne?
Ja, volle Gefühle.
Und dann Schmerzen auch.
Ja.
Und die Schmerzen wurden vom Patienten beim Atter, beim Beißen eingeordnet.
Und er berichtet, dass er gegen diese Schmerzen,
Novallin und Ibuprofen eingenommen haben.
Novallin und Ibuprofen hilft hat ein bisschen geholfen.
Novallin hat mehr geholfen.
Die Schmerzen sind in den Rücken und in der Schmerzen sind in den Rücken.
Und sie sind in Skapuna aus.
Und er berichtet auch über Blödengen.
Der Patient berichtet übergewicht,
dass er sich abnahmend von 3-4 kg in den nächsten vier Monaten.
Als er sich über die Schmerzen berichtet,
hat er die Üblichkeit beim Schmerzen.
Er hat gesagt, dass er ab uns zu Verstöpfen hat.
Er berichtet, dass er alle drei Tage einmal auf die Toilette gehe.
Konsistenz des Stürs sei fertig.
Als für Erdprogen gibt er Vogelblut, Arterelipertation,
Mann und seit fünf Jahren dagegen nimmt er am Nudupin 2,5 mg einmal Murgen ein.
Er wird seit vier Jahren bei den Patienten abwendet.
Er hat keine Allergie.
Er hat seit vier Jahren eine Pakumprotok.
Er trinkt jeden Tag 2-3 Glas Bier und anbrochen den Schnitz.
Seit 3-4 Jahren.
Er wird vom Patienten verneint.
Er ist in der Familie der Patienten.
Er hat den Patienten anmahgen können.
Er ist von zehn Jahren verstürbt.
Er ist mit dem Alter von 60 Jahren.
Er ist 60 Jahre alt und leidet an der Bundeswehr.
Wenn Sie haben eine gute Kurrenkarsen im Oberbauchschmerzen, ist es ungewöhnlich.
Ja.
Ja?
Mach sowas nicht.
Oberbauchschmerzen, welche Organe haben wir im Oberbauchbereich?
Ja.
Es kann Pakreskarsen sein.
Genau.
Noch?
Und Leberkarsen.
Vielleicht.
Ja, aber passt nicht natürlich.
Magenkarsen.
Ja?
Sie sagen, sich an Anamnesen konzentrieren.
Was könnte die Anamnesen, was führen oder was verursachen?
Ja, Kohletuck.
Ja, ich denke, am meisten an Pakreser.
Ja, ist nicht falsch.
Das ist wichtig.
Ja, noch?
Freundin, der Kollege, den hat etwas gefragt.
Könnte das Kohle-Span-Kredite sein?
Ja.
Das ist eine typische Kohle-Span-Kredite sein, Herr Mesa.
Da hat man chronische Schmelzen, da hat man einen gewichtabenden Namen, aber was wir
noch vergessen haben, Herr Mesa, hat Schweißausbruch, Fieber.
Die B-Symptomatik sollen sie vertiefen.
Ja.
Das sollen sie immer fragen.
Und Schlafsturmen.
Nicht Schlafsturmen, Schweißausbruch.
Ja.
Dieser Triat von B-Symptomatik.
Gewichtabend Narrenfieber und Schweißausbruch.
Die müssen sie immer fragen.
Aber sie haben vor Recht Pakres-Kastion, kann sein, das Kohlen-Span-Kredite.
Jetzt eine akute Schub von dem Kohlen-Span-Kredite, es könnte sein.
Was könnte er noch weiter sein?
Was ist das?
Scholangitis.
Scholangitis, zwei Monate, nur zwei Symptome, ungewöhnlich.
Fast nicht, aber kann man sagen, ja.
Aber der Kohlen-Gitis, drei Monate ist das Kohlen-Scholangitis, es kommt auch
eine Miesbezu-Wast rein, mit grünem Schmelzen kommt er nicht.
Scholelithiasis.
Scholelithiasis ist keine Erkrankung.
Wenn man Scholesystitis bei Lithiasis hat, haben sie Recht.
Das heißt Scholesystitis bei Lithiasis.
Scholelithiasis ist einfach, dass man die Steine in den Galenblase hat.
Die Kollegin als Chirurin würde sagen, kann man auch Steine im Galenblase haben,
solange man keinen Symptomat macht, macht man gar nichts, oder?
Ja.
Ja, ist okay.
Aber Scholesystitis bei Lithiasis, wenn man Entzündung hat, dann haben sie Recht, ja.
Passt auch nicht, aber nehmen wir das so an.
Weiter, Hepatitis.
Gut, ja genau, könnte auch sein.
Aber ob das ein typisches Hepatitis an einem Leser ist, das würde ich jetzt ver meinen.
Das würde ich sagen, nee, es ist nicht typischer Hepatitis an einem Leser.
Was ist denn typische Hepatitis an einem Leser?
Malgenkarsner.
Ja, guter Frage, ja, könnte sein, ja.
Aber wir haben es nicht genau vertieft.
Wir gehen malen, kannst du noch mal, aber könnte sein, natürlich.
Dünndarmverschluss, ungewöhnlich, wenn sie Dünndarmverschluss haben,
das ist ein akuter Fall, das ist kein akronisch Verlauf.
Das ist ein Notfall.
Wir machen jetzt den Brainestrom, jetzt machen wir weiter.
Was würden Sie als Hochwahrscheinlichkeit halten, das hier in diesen Anhandeln?
Ja, ich habe das schon.
Was würden Sie als Hochwahrscheinlichkeit halten?
Was könnte so ein Scheinchen, auch wahrscheinlich?
Wir haben viel an Diagnose jetzt hier gestellt, dass das denn sein kann,
das kann sein.
Ich würde sagen eher so eine Pankerskastnung oder chronische Pankeritis.
Aber der Rest kann man als differential Diagnose beinstellen.
Aber die beide ist mal das Wichtig, weil sie haben einen typischen Diagnose.
Der Patient raucht, der Patient bringt, hat chronische Bauchschmerzen,
Oberbauchschmerzen, hat Gewichtabnahme, ein bisschen Tomatik haben wir nicht genau gefragt,
aber wir nehmen an, das hat keine bisschen Tomatik, hat nur Gewichtabnahme.
Ja, und so eine Richteröre, zum Beispiel, ein fettes Stuhl,
ja, passt auch so eine chronische Pankeritis Geschichte.
Da passt nicht mit der Pankeritis, auch passt nicht auf Drehkne,
dann Repetitis, deswegen muss man sagen.
Und Pankerskrebs hat die Kollegin gesagt, Pankerskastnung,
und ja, dass eine exokreent Pankeris-Insoficienz-Symptome ist.
Das ist am meisten durch die Pankeritis oder die Pankeriskastnung.
Okay, was machen Sie als Diagnostik jetzt?
Sie haben Vermutung, was machen Sie?
Zuerst natürlich, ich möchte die Köpfbälligung untersuchen.
Genau.
Bei der Köpfbälligung wird auch bei dich die Bauch-Python.
Schmelzlokalisationen genau erfassen, wo das ist.
Ja.
Genau, und die Art von Schmelzeln, wie das ist,
das solln Sie auch machen, okay.
Weiter?
Die haben Patenten Blut abnehmen.
Okay.
Und so gleichzeitig Ultrasonografie durchführen brauchen.
Ultrasonografie.
Und gegenebendfalls möchte ich ein CT veranlassen.
Ja, genau, das ist richtig.
Aber so würde ich, wenn Sie direkt CT machen,
was würden Sie beim Blutuntersuchung achten?
Was würden Sie denn als erstes bestellen oder antworten?
Nierenwerte, das ist wichtig.
Was?
Nierenwerte, Kreativen.
Was werte, welche Werte habe ich nicht gehört, August?
Ja, aber Sie haben Verdacht auf Pankeritis da, warum Nierenwerte unbedingt?
Beide Kontrastorografie müssen wir...
Ja, aber für die Diagnose, was würden Sie jetzt erst mal als Blutuntersuchung achten?
Also, ja.
Amines, Pankeritis, Lipos.
Und...
Genau.
Ja.
Sehr, sehr klar.
Okay.
Da sind wir genau.
Und dann brauchen Sie auch natürlich bestimmte Nierenwerte wegen Nicht-Kontrastmittel alleine,
weil Grundspankeritis muss man unbedingt machen.
Sowieso Standard, fast bei jeder muss man machen, aber bei Grundspankeritis schon.
Leberwerte brauchen Sie auch.
Sie brauchen die Partite, die es mal hat, trotzdem.
Die Kollegin hat wächst, müssen Sie mitmachen.
Das ist halt eine differenzial Diagnose gehört dazu.
Und dann Grinnungs auch noch dazu, weil die Grinnungssturm kann auch anhand
den Grundspankeritis und dann auch Sekundär, Leber und Sufficiency seiner Grinnungsfaktorsturm
auch vorliegen.
Und daher machen Sie das auch.
Und dann machen Sie Unterscherell noch, das ist ja ein Recht.
Und dann, in diesem Fall, bei Vollegefüll und so etwas würde ich unbedingt eine
Rastoskopie fahren lassen.
Ja.
CT können Sie gerne machen, aber mit CT können Sie nicht im Mann in Halte sehen.
Das heißt, man muss uns unbedingt eine Rastoskopie machen.
Weil muss man sich nicht auf eine Diagnose konzentrieren, kann sein, dass mehrere Probleme
dahinter stehen, die wir nicht sehen können, auch nicht analysieren können.
Aber da muss man trotzdem jede Untersuchung durchführen.
Man macht auch eine Rastoskopie, das ist halt der Standard, um zu sehen, wie der Mann
ausseht, wie der Mann ausgang aus sieht.
Der Herr von Städtchenpankratitis hat eine Ausgangssthanose, das sind Sie auch nicht
genau, wenn es geschwollenes Druck auf den naren Ausgang ist.
Dann ist es eine Ingestelle, wo man sofort voller Gefühl bekommt.
Das ist auch eine andere Sache.
Und ja, CT haben Sie gemacht und was würden Sie als Behandlung machen?
Ich patente das Stationellaufnehmen und wenn es sogar einigen Flüssigkeit zufügt.
Ja, wie viel geben Sie denn?
Ja, 6 Liter.
Maximal, ja.
Oder bis 6 Liter, wenn der jung ist.
Wenn der alt ist, dürfen Sie nicht machen.
Da müssen Sie bis nach Kardiale statt achten.
Nicht, dass die Patienten einfach mit dem Wasser, mit Flüssigkeit pumpen und
dann passiert, steckt eine Herzinsuffizie.
Das müssen Sie genau balancieren, aber Sie brauchen richtig viel Flüssigkeit, damit
die Bank gespült wird und dann Schmerzhandstellung bis Mofin, müssen Sie einfach ein bisschen
Schmerzen haben, nur weil gehen die EV, wenn nicht ausreichend ist Mofin.
Punkt, da gibt es keine Diskussion.
Und Nahrungskarrens, machen Sie das in diesem Fall?
Es ist gar nicht so sicher.
Nein, Nahrungskarrens insgesamt, dass Sie das in einfach die Karrens bringen, dass Sie
gar nicht so sicher annehmen.
Würden Sie das machen?
Ja.
Fragen wir Ihnen wunderbar, macht man so Nahrungskarrens bei Grundspankerität
oder bei der Kurzspankerität so wurscht?
Nichtsima, wenn der Patient viel, äh, er will,
oder üblich, kann das, so wie wir Nahrungskarrens durschführen, aber ansonsten
wenn Patientin Nahrungsabnahme, äh, könne, kann, äh, könne, wie, ja, orale,
ernehmung.
Auch, da heißt, heißt Nahrungskarrens, solange das Passier ist nicht vertragen,
wenn Passier vertragt, das dürfen wir einfach zulassen, einfach gehen.
Haben Sie vollrecht, ja, genau.
Da gibt es keine Karrens, solange das Passier ist nicht vertragen.
Und Passier ist nicht, ich kann das nicht, dann ist das Karrens, selbst von sich alleine.
Ist nicht von eurem, unsere Seite auch das Passier ist nicht.
Und Passier sagt, ich bin in der Lage, das ich etwas so nicht einnehme, dann lassen
Sie, lassen Sie trinken Sie, solange das ist vertragen.
Da gab es in der Altenleitlinie, dass man Nahrungskarrens durschsitzt, und
dann gibt es heute Tage, dass man den sobald wie möglich wieder einsitzt, solange
das Passier vertragen.
Wie lange Alkoholkarenz?
Das ist unbedingt, das würden Sie nicht schaffen, ja.
Im Krankenhaus, die Alkoholiker, die haben in der Tasche auch immer was.
Wenn Sie im Schrank gehen, dann würden Sie auch etwas finden.
Das sagen Sie denn, ja, Alkohol auch nicht alleine, Rauchen ist auch
eine große Faktor, die wir vergessen, ja.
Cigarette ist Rauchen, ist eine große Usachafanfetik, das auch.
Und Pankehreskrebs auch, das vergessen wir dann meistens.
Man empfehlt natürlich, ich könnte Sie nichts Vieles machen, ja.
Aber das ist halt so sehr unverfügig.
Okay, Flüssigkeit haben wir gesagt, Schmerztherapiegelung,
Nahrungskarrens haben wir auch erklärt, wie das ist,
Diagnostik haben wir auch gemacht.
Und Pankehres, ein Kollege hat geschrieben, Krebsmarker,
kann man machen, es ist ja 1999, das tut mich für den Pankehres,
aber ja, das ist halt so, wenn man so verdacht, das muss man machen,
ja, in diesem Fall.
Ansonsten muss man es mal behandeln und das da auch so ein paar Wochen,
das ist etwas sindlicher Hult, ja, wenn wir eine Entzündung haben,
wenn Pankehres nicht so schnell halten war.
Aber muss man beobachten, weil Pankehres,
Pankehres, Pankehretitis ist eine Usachafanfetik für Pankehreskrebs.
ESCP macht man nicht, überhaupt nicht so lange,
man ist nicht sicher, dass man eine Schulduchulitiasis hat,
die eine Pankehretitis verursacht hat.
Das heißt, wenn Sie sicher sind, dafür bräunen Sie eine MRCP,
das heißt, Sie machen eine MRCP, um den Schulduchulitiasis
einfach da zu stehen, die ganze Galangänge,
ob Sie eine Stein dort haben, wenn Sie vermuten,
dass eine Steinabgang ist und die Gang verschroffert,
dann machen Sie eine ESCP, aber weil die Komplikation für eine ESCP
sicher ist, dass es auch eine Pankehretitis ist.
Das heißt, es hat aktuell eine Pankehretitis
und Sie gehen auch noch mit einer Gerät rein
und dann verschlemmen Sie die Situation noch.
Solange Sie nicht sicher sind, keine ESCP,
aber wenn Sie vermuten, dass die Pankehretitis
nicht eine etyltuchstürz, sondern auch eine Stein
oder eine Abflusssturung ist durch den Steinabgang,
dann müssen Sie es machen.
Ist das klar?
Als Späger oder wie die New Yorker?
Ja, okay.
Sehr gut.